dans les bureaux de vote de niamey les
électeurs masqués se sont succédé toute
la journée dans le calme pour cette
élection présidentielle couplée aux
législatives
ils étaient plus de 7 millions
d'électeurs appelés à se rendre aux
urnes en lice trente candidats dont en
grand favori
mohamed bazoum ancien ministre de
l'intérieur et bras droit du président
sortant candidat du parti au pouvoir
il a appelé ses militants à voter en
masse pour lui c'est la première fois
depuis que je participe à des élections
deux trains toiles les plus récurrents
comme la circonscription de basket
d ailleurs les bureaux de vote et peut
être mise en place d'abris plus tôt
qu'aujourd'hui même les laitages leur
demander de sortir langoureux comme ils
l'ont fait les tresses encore plus
nombreux en cas de victoire mohamed
bazoum succéderait à mamadou issoufou
qui a décidé de respecter la
constitution et de ne pas se représenter
après ses deux mandats
cette élection présidentielle se déroule
dans un pays où les coups d'état ont été
nombreux depuis son indépendance en 1960
dans ce contexte les nigériens attendent
beaucoup de leur futur président
maintenant on aimerait quand même à voir
plus de c'est pas moi dans le train et
de tête de stabilité surtout et que le
g20 se mette au travail
nous prions dieu vous qui nous
choisissent le président qui a le plus
pitié pour le peuple
un président tu ne vas pas trahir le
pays et qui ne trahira pas la confiance
du peuple
c'est notre seule à ce que je puisse
aider à faire le bonheur des pauvres
paysans et les éleveurs
durant sa campagne mohamed bazoum a
notamment promis de développer la
sécurité et l'éducation
mais pour le prochain président nigérien
il s'agira surtout de renforcer la lutte
contre les groupes djihadistes ce mois
ci deux attaques ont coûté la vie à des
dizaines de nigériens dans l'ouest et
dans l'est du pays où sévit notamment
boko haram
les premières estimations des élections
nigérianes sont attendus ce lundi les
résultats définitifs pourraient quant à
eux être connue mercredi ou jeudi
prochain